who else has a job that tick-tock made
us hate anybody
what's up ladies how do you guys know
each other
work where
biopharma we all just accept that
none of us know what it means it sounds
impressive
is it impressive what does it mean
biopharma it sounds like the same thing
a little bit
you make vaccines
see how quiet the anti-vaccine-ass
audience got
they don't trust you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
hey three people clapped and the rest of
this republican ass on he's like get
this [ __ ]
[Applause]
hey she put microchips in us
that's the [ __ ]
yo yo ain't that crazy you saved the
world and the internet made everybody
think you're killing us
all you saved the [ __ ] planet and
because of the internet this whole
audience is like this evil [ __ ]
stopping a pandemic so she could
microchip us
i got so many fat [ __ ] friends
not taking this vaccine it's like
brother
you suddenly now care about your health
i'll die heart disease but not from a
vaccine
you want four blood pressure medications
and now you don't trust medicine
if you're a [ __ ] guy who works out
every day you watch what you eat and
you're like i don't know about the
vaccine look i don't agree but i can't
argue with you
good for you but if you are about to
lose a [ __ ]
foot anyway like wait
just take a shot dog
[Applause]
don't you want to feel something in your
left arm before you grab it mid-stroke
you work on vaccines also which company
ajinomoto you ain't make no vaccine
nobody heard of
you ever walk through walmart and you
look at a high sense tv and you're like
what the [ __ ] is hisense
they just slapped some japanese name on
it so they're like oh they must be smart
we ain't never heard of no [ __ ]
ajinamoto son i heard a johnson and
johnson
i ain't heard of ajinamoto
you did moderna g's up i got moderna
okay all right
so if i die i'm [ __ ] y'all up
life i'm coming back haunting the [ __ ]
out of you
yo the internet is a fascinating place
man we respect
them not at all and [ __ ] were like hey
give them their props
that's funny hey sex workers come on
show them some respect
they're not criminals like scientists
what an odd thing
what's up guys thanks for watching the
video if you're a fan just hit subscribe
stop hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming after warranty
you